In the case of full virtualization, the operating system thinks that it
owns all the devices already. And the way devices are virtualized, is the
familiar trap and emulate technique. That is for the devices
that the operating system thinks it owns when it tries to make
any access. To those devices, it's going to result in a trap into
the hyperviser and the hyperviser will emulate
the functionality that the Operating System intends for
that particular device. In this sense, there
is not much scope for innovation in the
way devices are virtualized in a fully
virtualized environment. A lots of details of course,
that the hyperviser has to worry about,
once the guest. Trans into the hypervisor to
ensure the legality of the I/O operation and also whether the guest is allowed
to make those I/O operations and so on, but nothing fundamental conceptually.
Is there in terms of device
virtualization in a fully virtualized environment. Para
virtualized setting is much more interesting. The IO devices seen by the guest
operating system are exactly the ones that
are available to the hypervisor. That is, the
set of hardware devices That are available
in the platform are exactly the one that
the para-virtualized guest operating system is going
to be able to manipulate. This gives an
opportunity for innovating the interaction between the
guest operating system and the hypervisor, in particular
ways in which we can make Device virtualization more efficient when we have this
para-virtualized environment. So for one thing, it
is possible for the hypervisor to come up
with clean and simple device abstractions that
can be used by the para-virtualized operating
system. Further, through APIs, it becomes possible
For the hypervisor to expose shared buffers to
the guest operating system. So that efficiently
data can be passed between the guest
operating system and the hypervisor and to
the devices without incurring the overhead of
copying multiple times data from one address
space into another. And similarly, there can
be innovations in the way event delivery
happens between the hypervisor and the guest
operating system. So, in order to do
device virtualization, we have to worry about two
things. One is how to transfer control
back and forth between the hypervisor and the
guest. Because, devices being hardware entities They
need manipulation by the hypervisor in a privileged
state. And there is a data transfer that needs to be done because the hypervisor
is in a different protection domain compared to the guest operating system.
So these are two things that one has to worry about in
device virtualization and we'll see how both control transfer. And data transfer
at accomplished in both the fully virtualized and the para virtualized settings.